welcome everybody uh to the state of
production machine learning uh in
2023 uh I am really excited uh to be
talking about a very broad range of very
relevant topics um across the machine
learning
ecosystem um and uh we'll be able to
delve into uh content that you will be
able to um yeah revisit later on uh with
the resources provided um you will find
the slides uh in this link at the top
right so yeah if you missed uh some of
the uh talk you'll be able to um you
know catch up on on that uh on your own
time a bit about my about myself uh so
my name is Alejandro I am uh director of
Technology at
zando uh a uh uh large tech company uh
based in Europe uh based focusing mainly
on e-commerce I'm also scientific
adviser at The Institute for ethical Ai
and machine learning um a research
center that um contributes to um policy
and standards for the responsible
development deployment and operation of
machine learning systems and I'm also a
governing council member at large uh at
the ACM where I contribute to to policy
as well as um to uh strategic
initiatives uh related to uh AI um and
yeah like I said um you know this talk
is actually going to be referencing a
lot of uh material including uh several
of my previous talks at previous uh Pi
data uh and other conferences so you
will see any references here and because
it's a very broad um overview of the
state of production machine learning uh
we will be covering a lot of content
each of the slides is basically kind of
maybe like a summary of of an entire
Deep dive so you'll be able to uh delve
into into that um um you know as you
find most interesting so yeah let's uh
uh oh before we dive into um I also
collected a couple of relevant talks
that you may be interested about so
things across responsible AI uh
explainability machine learning
monitoring metadata as well as machine
learning security uh that you'll be able
to to dive into so the key uh points
that we will be covering today include
the motivations and challenges the
industry and domain Trends some
technological Trends some organizational
Trends and then we're going to be
wrapping up so let's dive first into the
motivations and challenges so one thing
that has now become more or less
consensus is that the machine learn the
life cycle of a machine learning model
does not finish once you train it right
once you actually achieve that
performance metric whether it's accuracy
precision recall whatever it is um uh uh
you know IMC whatever whatever kind of
like metric that you have um once you
actually finish training your model um
it doesn't finish there right the life
cycle of the machine learning model
actually begins once it's trained and
once it's actually being used uh uh in
production or in the particular use
cases and the interesting point about
this is that there are a large number of
uh considerations uh that have to be
taken into account when we move into
this uh different uh uh space you know
whether it is things like outliers
changes of the data itself
distributions uh uh concept drift uh um
you know the reproducibility components
etc etc so this is basically some of the
the the hints of things that we're going
to be delving into but if we ask the
question of why is production machine
learning so challenging I mean there are
a large kind of like laundry list of
reasons but some of the uh Keys uh areas
that we can highlight here is different
to for example traditional software
right and and traditional U
microservices for example is that there
is a need for specialized Hardware right
so things like GPU tpus but also U
models that may require extra amount of
compute or extra uh large amounts of
memory uh to run and to be able to load
them right even like like RAM memory um
um as part of this um there is also the
complex data flows right like different
components different pipelines that are
being productionize or different machine
Learning Systems as we'll be explaining
later down the line that actually have
different uh uh steps where something
that goes wrong could affect things
uh you know down the streams or even up
the stream there are considerations
around the compliance right um um that
allows that that brings um you know
questions around uh things that you may
have heard uh like AI ethics uh the the
challenges that will actually cover in a
bit more depth uh in a bit uh but also
things like reproducibility right how
how do you make sure that whatever you
ran last Tuesday is going to actually
run again if you want to like debug it
or you want to rerun it right so these
are some of the the higher level
challenges but it actually goes into the
domain as well right because uh when it
comes to machine learning use cases um
they tend to you know tackle particular
um um you know areas uh that could also
create uh potential uh challenges and
potential risks that have to be taken
into consideration and we've seen uh you
probably have seen also areas like
algorithmic bias um more traditional
things like software outages that can
affect machine Learning Systems in
different ways um personal data uh in
itself and considerations around that
when it comes to to machine learning uh
and and AI as well as the cyber security
uh nuances that will'll also be delving
in too um but yeah uh with this we have
to remember that that you know the
impact of a bad solution can be worse
than no solution at all and uh this is
also why we care and why we should care
about uh this uh in that in that sense
and that kind of adds another element uh
uh to the mix which of course you know
we wer going to talk about the state of
production machine learning without
mentioning mention in uh you know llms
or generative AI but one thing that I do
want to call out that will be relevant
throughout the talk is that when it
comes to um um the architectural
patterns that um are arising in the rise
of uh llms more specifically this agent
chain architectures that we'll talk
about later they are a very good way of
visualizing and getting an intuition of
these production challenges of machine
learning that goes beyond the LMS right
and we will talk about uh some of the
the the nuances there now in terms of
the uh roles we also have to take into
consideration that in order to tackle
and and understand what the nuances uh
and requirements for production machine
learning are are the different
responsibilities so traditionally we
have the data scientists the devops the
software engineering but now we're
seeing the rise and the standardization
of the machine learning engineer and
also of the machine learning of the
mlops engineer we'll reference a little
bit more of that in theer in the
organizational Trends but then you have
this new role and and it it has also
extended into the higher level around
that intersection of the industry domain
expertise and the policy expertise to
bring in what are those AIML standards
or best practices so this is actually
something that is that is important
because you know it is it is going from
a best practice locally to a best
practice that becomes uh uh uh more
adopted so that is one of the high
levels of why why should we care now in
terms of uh you know some of the
industry trends that we see is that
we're starting to see you know kind of
uh the way that that I like to think
about it 2016 and and around those dates
were the dates of the principles where
every organization was publishing a
principle and a set of guidelines um
however as it progressed then it moved
from um you know this this this sort of
more higher level into more you know
kind of like uh um industry standards
regulatory Frameworks right now we're
actually starting to see some Frameworks
within uh you know Europe to actually
come to life uh for Regulatory
Compliance and we are also seeing the
importance of uh going one level even
deeper on the software libraries right
how making sure that the underlying
foundations are built in a way that
actually are uh possible to to to align
with those higher level principles but
then we also have to think about it that
uh this um very kind of like important
uh uh uh uh responsible ethical
questions cannot fall on the shoulder of
a single data scientist or a single
single practitioner and even though it
is important to make sure that you know
as an individual you can adopt best
practices
uh you know making sure that you're
having the right domain expertise the
competence in the field the competence
in the area professional responsibility
it also requires different layers
including that team delivery process
right cross functional skill sets within
the area key domain expertise
accountability structures principal
alignment but then it also goes uh at a
department or organizational level uh
where we're seeing that pattern of
introducing um you know governing
structures uh uh you know um human touch
points throughout you know AI systems uh
human in the loop uh requirements and
then also risk assessments which we'll
talk about in a bit as part of that we
also see as I mentioned that uh policy
is actually um advancing at quite a fast
pace and whilst before uh you know we
often uh mention how regulation is
playing catch-up we now see that it is
the compliance that is uh now aiming to
to to align with the regulation that is
coming up and uh it has been really
interesting to see a lot of those
Frameworks that have been coming up um
um across the ecosystem um that have uh
in many many areas will be having some
some positive outcomes introducing uh
best practices and uh in this pyramid
that I was talking about what is really
interesting is this is this alignment
between those higher level
principles and also the underlying
Foundation right whether it's the open
source code or the actual you know
software code that is that is uh
developed for the for the particular use
case um those principles are you know
useless if the foundation is not in
place right and this is actually
important because it brings us as
practitioners as a critical component in
this uh uh uh discussions and areas
right so that's some some of high level
industry and the main Trends as I said
uh you know there's a couple of like uh
links uh you know one hour plus sessions
where you will be able to like delve
into a bit more detail if you're
interested so then diving into some of
the technological Trends which I think
you know I guess in this session is a
bit of the the meat uh of the
presentation um I want to just paint the
picture right like um uh uh when it
comes to machine learning Frameworks and
mlops Frameworks uh we remember all how
it started right like ultimately you all
were uh looking to you know pull kind of
like a one of the usual uh um suspects
for the um machine learning Frameworks
you were basically running like a a
usual um you know cart 10 and then you
know you're able to kind of like get
some insights of of your model then you
can apply it kind like into a notebook
and and uh you know rinse and repeat uh
as as you're kind of like honing honing
down uh of course it's oversimplifying
it but you know this is kind of like how
how it started but now if we look at how
it's going uh we we are kind of like uh
uh you know hit on the face with like so
much choice and so much uh set of like
tools framework Technologies areas uh uh
components that we should that we could
choose or we could not choose right and
when it comes to kind of like navigating
this ecosystem we have to ask ourselves
like how as practitioners can we really
navigate this effectively one of the
things that we have done uh at The
Institute for ethical ethical AI we
published a resource uh that has been
growing really really fast uh that has
been aiming to collect some of uh um
actively maintained and used Frameworks
in the machine learning space across
different areas you know explainability
privacy preserving machine learning
automl you know visualizations
optimization etc etc so U yeah please do
check it out if if you find that one is
missing please contribute it uh that is
the beauty of Open Source but this has
allowed us to actually like delve into
this question a little bit deeper and we
have found some resources that are
pretty actionable and uh can be quite
practical um before diving into those
resources let's first get take a step
back and think about what do we talk
about when we refer to the production
machine learning ecosystem and let's
take what we could call an archetypal um
architectural blueprint right it's like
what could we reduce uh machine learning
in production to of course super
simplified uh because you know it's
never going to be this simple but let's
think about it first in this sort of
concept where you have training data
your artifacts and then your inference
data right you will uh want to actually
perform uh what would be experimentation
right whether is in a notebook or in a
distributed workflow manager
hyperparameter tuning training
evaluation to you know use training data
to create some models you would then be
able to want to actually make those
models ail available whether is somebody
clicking a button or having some sort of
um programmatic way of delivering that
right whether it's building like the
actual images or or or or or or running
tests Etc you want to productionize your
models right and this could be perhaps
whether it's real time or whether is
batch right and once you have that you
want to also Advance uh add some
Advanced monitoring or or or just some
usual monitoring right and we're going
to talk about that um as data goes
through your models as as well as
through your monitoring you would be
able to capture some of that data which
then you would be able to you know have
a full cycle in the ideal world and of
course throughout this you have metadata
flowing uh from end to end right however
when we ask the question of like hey
well what tools should we be adopting
one thing that one uh uh component that
we have found that is very useful is
this myops tool which basically creates
some kind of uh components that uh serve
as the uh sort of like yes archetypal um
um um areas where you can uh choose and
swap different tooling right so here you
would have your experiment tracking
experimentation data versioning Cod
versioning pipeline orchestration model
registry serving blah blah etc etc and
you can pick and choose um you know what
would work best for you for your
organization and sometimes you know when
it's a very small kind of like context
you know you actually probably do more
harm than good bringing too much of a
stack but for organizations that are
growing you know this is what often uh
has to be considered now in terms of
this sort of con consideration yes we're
thinking about the different components
but not only we see a shift in terms of
the uh components that that you know
often are required to actually have a
robust uh framework and of course when
we're talking about this canonical stack
Um this can also be a single end to-end
provider right like like a single one
which has end to end coverage and there
is a lot of kind of like you know
discussion of where is Best of breed
versus kind of like end to endend but
ultimately you know a lot of the times
there is kind of like context but we're
also moving into a situation where we're
no longer productionizing model right
and this is what we are what I was
suggesting that um the the area of the
llms actually visualizes quite well but
in the traditional not traditional but
in the more kind of like common large
scale machine learning applications we
see a situation where we're not
productionizing a machine learning model
we're productionizing machine Learning
Systems right and as part of this you
can actually see this is uh the
embedding based retrieval uh framework
for meta uh for actual search you can
see here that you have like an offline
component that actually builds the
embeddings that has multi uh steps even
those quantization you then have kind of
like the online component which does the
the ranking the retrieval the query
processing so here we're talking about
you know a multi-stage complex machine
Learning System and when you think about
your infrastructure you have to think
about also this in mind so this is
actually something that now brings new
nuances that brings us from not just the
from machine learning model to machine
Learning System but from model Centric
to data Centric and again going back to
this kind of like you know pointer of
the llm is that there is why I keep
repeating it is because it's often hard
to actually verbalize in an intuitive
way this machine Learning System
component but with the introduction of
kind of like this agent chain
architectures it's easier to think about
it right like an llm interacting with
other apis orchestrating kind of like
interactions to be able to return a
response uh requested by a user right so
so that is something that um you know is
is is is allowing it would allow you to
kind of like uh build an intuition on
what uh is meant by this point now of
course there are considerations uh when
it comes to thinking about the concept
of models and uh when it comes to a
machine learning model we often think
about it in the same way that you know a
model um a experimentation tracking
system thinks about it right it thinks
about it as the the train models so
let's think about for example we have an
a set of data a set of data with data
instances A1 to a and we train a a
machine learning model right uh we train
machine learning Model A with a sub set
right of data now we train another uh uh
machine learning model and then another
one until we train M machine learning
models with different sets of data right
so this is what we're used to right
actually being able to identify our
machine learning models as artifacts and
being able to store metadata about them
being able to like you know think about
them and and and reason about them uh
this way however and yeah multiple
different model B Etc but now when you
put these things into production you
have a New Concept right you let's say
you deploy uh Model A M in environment X
right so here is is an instantiation of
your of your artifact but you may also
instantiate that I mean I'm calling it
instantiation deployment into another
environment environment why and then you
deploy a pipeline that consists of this
model and this model right in another
environment right so here the metadata
that is involved here the considerations
that are involved here even though you
indeed are referencing the same machine
learning model you have a completely
different relationship and different
conceptual way of thinking of your
production ecosystem right and this
introduces new con uh uh um
considerations when thinking about your
your production machine Learning Systems
because it really brings the hardest of
machine learning with the hardest of
traditional software you know at scale
distributed systems microservices Etc
right so but together um and with that
you have uh you know the whole host of
considerations right one of them that we
talked about was monitoring right
so uh monitoring itself is something
that we would then have to introduce to
all of these instantiations right like
your model deployed over here your model
deployed over there so it's important to
think about the monitoring in the same
way that you would have with
microservices right like your
performance right CPU Ram Etc whether
there's a memory leak you can identify
it but also machine learning specific uh
uh nuances like statistical performance
you know what is the the the accuracy
precision recall when it's in production
the nuances of the
data kind of architecture that you need
in order to be able to like you know uh
capture um um you know actual uh labels
um and explainability techniques and
real down on metrics but then it's also
going from monitoring into observability
right this is things like introducing
alerting automated slos SLI service
level objectives and then also having
like automated way of production I think
things like like Progressive rollouts
canaries Etc so I mean yeah you you can
see here that there is kind of like a
trend towards intersecting from the best
practices of distributed systems uh
large scale software into into the
machine learning space but the key thing
is that you know as as as data science
practitioners we also want to not have
to care about this and we're talk going
to talk about that a little bit more in
the organizational side besides
monitoring we also have to consider
security right and one thing that we
have to know about security is in terms
of Trends is that uh uh security is
becoming now a big topic and the reason
why is because the area where you have
to consider security is that every
single stage of the machine learning
pipeline right it's not only in the data
cleansing it's not only on the building
of the model it's not only on the
deployment it's at every stage of the
machine learning life cycle and U you
know again one of the things that we
have been able to see uh we published a
resource called the ml secops top 10
which is analogous to the OAS top 10 now
oasp actually publish their own top 10
for llms and for you know traditional
machine learning so I would recommend
you to actually check it out because
even as practitioners data science
practitioners machine learning
practitioners this gives you an
intuition of what are some best practic
that you can adopt and also what are
some best practic that can be rolled out
right things around poison pickles on
loading model artifacts uh uh poison uh
poison data uh access to the model how
that can lead into things like
adversarial attacks uh dependencies
bringing kind of like supply chain uh
security into the into the play etc etc
so I do definitely recommend it and
we're running actually a uh machine
learning security um com committee
within the Linux Foundation that is
exploring these areas which has had some
really interesting um outcomes there
okay so then uh the final Point diving
into some organizational Trends um so we
talked about the technology side but now
let's talk about the organization right
because as machine learning
practitioners you know you can't be a
unicorn all the time every everywhere
right you can't have a data scientist
that is handling all of the
productionizing all of the
experimentation and all all of the
domain right um especially as
organizations grow you know these are
considerations to to think about and
these are trends that we're seeing sort
of like the industry consolidate towards
so one trend is basically moving from uh
trying to to take the uh software
development life cycle what you would
normally use in your in your sdlc and
copy paste it into into your machine
learning space there is now a consensus
that you know that shouldn't be the best
approach and then instead you should
have a machine learning development life
cycle which is more akin to a uh fit for
context right and you would basically be
able to bring in uh the the most
relevant areas um um for the different
components right so uh that is one of
the the the the trends is actually
organizations bringing that
standardization of process uh uh to be
able to move their machine learning
through their production line let's call
it the second one is an interesting
intersection between the emops and the
data Ops departments so in the data Ops
you would have the concepts of like data
mesh how organizations are introducing
Analytics to be able to take advantage
of uh their uh data ecosystem from an
analytical standpoint um but this is
starting to intersect a lot into the
machine learning production side and how
to bring both of those world together
how to bring in the requirements of you
know data governance with also the
requirements of machine learning
governance within a single strategy
right it's supposed to kind of like
having a data strategy a machine
learning strategy kind of like
completely separate so this is another
interesting organizational Trend the
third one is is kind of this concept of
metadata interoperability we talked
about the different sort of like uh
heterogeneous systems that organizations
often bring in not only often they bring
in different um like systems but they
may have different system for different
units right and as part of this what is
important is to make sure that there's
sort of like homogeneity or
standardization in how metadata flows
across right such that irrespective of
whether you have heterogeneous
components you can have homogeneous
interfaces and there something that
we're see at the different uh sort of
like stages uh and uh areas of of
machine learning because it's a need
that uh you know organizations need to
bring another um um um concept
organizationally is this mindset going
from machine learning projects where you
basically just deliver an outcome
deliver an answer let's call it right
you deliver an answer moving into more
of a mindset of products and bringing
this product thinking into the machine
learning space going into this iterative
agile uh means of actually delivering
incremental value uh producti in
capabilities that then feed into
themselves and and iteratively allow uh
stakeholders or domain or users to
actually work at a higher level as part
of this then also comes the
organizational structure and we are
starting to see this the concept that is
often you know ubiquitous in the
traditional software space around squads
and like multi cross functional squads
coming into the machine learning space
we no longer you may have just data
analysts and and and and data scientists
but now you may have actually ux
researchers fullstack Engineers machine
learning Engineers machine learning
researchers mlops Engineers acting kind
of like in a in a very sort of like um
agile unit specific uh uh perspective so
that's another interesting one then
actually mapping of course the
technological outputs into the business
outcomes having different Cadence for
the different road maps around your
iterative tooling development your uh
you know tools and products that can be
reused across other teams and then also
the infrastructure that is used across
the board right and this you know even
though it brings some initial kind of uh
effort and and some potential kind of
like slowdown it introduces
standardization that eventually speeds
up uh the outcome delivery now in terms
of the the the organizational shapes um
one pattern that we see is that
organizations tend to adopt too much too
early in their uh Journey right so if
you just have a small team of data
scientists is very different to you and
a few models is very different to having
a you know large L ger group of of data
scientists with more models uh and then
you know a significantly larger number
of data scientists with many machine
learning Engineers right so as part of
you know going kind of like into that uh
stack you also have to consider how you
grow as as as your uh requirements
develop right in terms of automation
standardization control security
observability reliability but also in
terms of the roles themselves and the
roles themselves that we see is like I
said right is if you have a small group
of data scientists they can operate by
themselves as they start churning out
significantly more models and they start
uh becoming busier uh by just
operationalizing stuff that's when it's
relevant to start bringing machine
learning Engineers to be able to own
that that that space right to be able to
create reusable pipelines now as this
even grow further right this is when
actually having multiple different sort
of considerations in in terms of
delivery of of applied science that's
when we start seeing this role of the
mlops engineer bringing kind of
capabilities at the platform level so
this is a very interesting Trend that we
definitely do see and you can see that
this you know can grow and grow and grow
uh but these are some Trends and some
patterns that we see so yeah so those
are some organizational patterns now in
terms of uh uh you know the wrapup what
I just want to also highlight is that
yeah when you're running around with a
hammer everything can look like a nail
right and not everything can or should
be solved with AI right there's a large
number of problems in the world and
there's a very small number of solutions
that should be kind of solving those
specific problems so that's something to
think about as practitioners I know also
the second thing and just the thing that
I want to kind close in is that um you
know we have to be aware that now
critical infrastructure is increasingly
dependent on machine Learning Systems
however regardless of how many layers of
software and hardware and ml abstraction
there is the impact will always be human
right at an individual at a societal
level so that means that you know it
doesn't matter how many chatbots or llms
you're introducing there's there's going
to be indeed some automation but it's
not going to be kind of like removing
completely uh you know everything from
the equation and the impact is still
human right so that's something to
consider as well and with that I want to
thank everybody um I hope you enjoyed
this session on the state of production
machine learning in 2023 uh like I said
you can find the slides uh in this link
um uh you know if you if you didn't
manage to catch up a couple of Concepts
or or areas you'll be able to catch up
at your own time um and you can then
visit also the links provided so with
that uh thank you very
much
thank you so much Alejandra that was
fantastic
um I think we have time for a question
or two from the audience if anyone has
any questions um Alejandra would it be
possible for you to share your slides in
Discord um I actually don't have the
link would you be able to help me with
that if I share the link with you yeah
absolutely oh thank you so much let me
send it over there you go
thank you I will post it on your behalf
and um for those that would like to join
the
Discord here is the invite
link thank you and and I can see some
really nice comments uh thank you so
much nice comments in the chat session
is pure gold yeah I'll take that one uh
thank you
yeah
yeah and then there's one on um if we
have some organization some resources on
organizational Trends yeah I mean I'd
love for there to be a bit more uh I
would say start with the slides and
check the links because there's enough
links to keep you busy and there were a
couple of links on the organizational
Trends uh section
yeah I can see there's a quick question
uh do we have time maybe for like a one
minute answer
yeah if we'll keep it quick I'll put
this on stage are squads permanent teams
are formed around projects yeah that's a
great question so I would recommend you
to check out the research from Spotify
which basically like that's where kind
of like concept of of of squads tribes
Etc was was presented um they tend to be
yeah temporary um and separate to the
organizational hierarchical structure uh
and they're set up for the particular
process Pro um for the particular in
initiative U but yeah I mean explains it
much better and this is not now just a
proposal to bring it into into machine
learning and how we've been seeing it
quite quite effectively yeah